The sheer quantity and
quality that we have here
at the Arizona State Museum
is unmatched in the southwest.
It's really a
testament to long term
preservation of
the arid Southwest.
If you look closely, you'll
see a huge amount of variety
and you have to imagine
that somebody picked
a piece of fiber or grass
and wove it together
to create something functional.
There's many people that
believe that working
with fiber and basketry is
the oldest human technology.
I've always been interested
in cultural heritage
and I like doing
things with my hands,
so this is a perfect combination
of art history, science,
and fine art.
We've had lots of conversations
with basket weavers
and cultural representatives in
putting this exhibit together
and time after time, it's
connecting to the past,
it's connecting
within families, it's
connecting to the environment.
It's part of a really
essential heritage
that so many native
communities in Arizona have.